Prof: As we approach the
episode of Camacho's wedding it
should be readily apparent that
it was--
the story was going to be a
play.
It has a beginning,
a conflict or climax,
and a resolution.
Given that it has a happy
ending its safe to assume that
it was going to be a comedy.
Actually, scholars have
ferreted around and discovered
evidence that,
indeed, it was a play that
Cervantes was planning to write.
And Cervantes,
it seems, found in the
Quixote a book where he
could sort of dump all of his
work in progress,
the stories,
some of which wound up,
of course, in the book
Exemplary Stories,
but some of the stories in the
book,
of course, were written
independently and had actually
circulated independently.
The novel, as it is being
developed in the Quixote,
will be an inclusive kind of
literary work,
with a lose format,
not following the strict rules
of literary forms,
genres, derived from the
classical tradition where these
liberties were not available,
but the Quixote does
allow for this kind of
incorporation of stories and of
various texts.
It is a feature that the novel
will continue to have and that
in the modern period,
of course, will be exploited to
the very limits.
Let us also notice how this
love story is neatly integrated
into the plot of the novel,
as opposed to the more
tangential way in which such
stories were inserted in Part
II.
Here, Don Quixote and Sancho
are more or less involved in the
developments,
and certainly Don Quixote is
involved in the outcome.
Of course, given that this was
going to be a play,
there is a great deal of
theatricality in the whole
episode,
which includes theater within
the theater as these
celebrations for the wedding
take place.
Even nature has been
artistically arranged,
so much so, that the outdoors
now has a roof.
You may recall that,
when they enter the meadow
where the celebration of the
wedding is going to take place,
it is noted that the trees have
been arranged in such a way as
to provide a canopy that the sun
can barely penetrate to reach
the grass.
That is, is nature turned into
architecture,
as it were.
The play within the play is a
way of underlining that
everything is theatrical;
that there is no real action
that is not already theater.
That is, life is already
theater in Part II,
and this is part of the theme
of desengaño that
I have been underlining for the
past few lectures.
Let us also take notice of the
abundance that prevails here and
in the second part,
in general, in contrast with
Part I.
Whereas, in Part I,
the characters ate frugally,
now Sancho has so much food
before him that he scarcely
knows what to do with it.
Compare this with the very
frugal meal that Don Quixote had
at that very first inn,
when he ate fish because it was
Friday.
Abundance, contrasted with the
starkest want is typical of the
aesthetics of the Baroque,
this clash, and abundance ties
in with the notion of
sensuality,
the sensuality of Cervantes's
art that Auerbach spoke about in
the essay that you have all
read,
and that he says is the
hallmark of Cervantes' work.
The sensual,
the tangible,
in all its abundance,
turns into a simulacrum and
reveals its opposite,
which is quite literary death.
This is the
desengaño aspect.
So we have Sancho's speech
about death being the devourer
of all.
As I said, the overarching plot
and the plot within the work in
these stories follows this
pattern of engaño
and desengaño.
Now, we may ask when we come to
this episode,
why are weddings so important
in fiction,
including film,
of course, the theater too,
but in film,
there are many films that you,
I'm sure, can remember,
that center on a wedding.
Weddings mark a moment of
social union and renewal,
both of society and of nature.
They are a transition marked by
feasting, particularly,
by eating.
In fiction, weddings tend to be
conclusions: 'they married and
lived happily ever after,' is a
common and traditional ending to
stories.
In the wedding celebrations the
world is consumed in a way that
leads to the consummation of the
marriage.
The story--and we will see much
more about this in a very short
time--
the story of Camacho's wedding,
like the myth of Pyramus and
Thisbe on which it is based,
is a conjunction of love and
death of Eros and Thanatos,
or love that struggles against
death for continuity and
renewal.
There are intimations of the
death scene,
the culminating death scene,
which is really not a death
scene,
but a contrived theatrical
death scene,
but there are intimations of
that death scene in the calf
that is impaled to be cooked
that our protagonists find as
they arrive at the wedding
celebration.
One could also see in that
impaled calf a scapegoat,
which is typical of feasts and
of celebrations.
Now, Camacho is rich and
powerful like Don Fernando in
Part I.
But Basilio's abilities and
skills prevail over social and
economic forces.
His industria,
his abilities win the day,
and there is much made of how
many skills he has,
he can play the guitar,
he is an athlete,
we later find out that he's
quite an actor,
also.
Now, the episode is a prose
epithalamium,
and I think better write
this--a poem or song in praise
of the bride or groom or both
from the Greek
"epi,"
"at,"
and
"thalamium,"
"nuptial chamber"--
and a verse epithalamium is
actually performed as part of
the wedding celebration,
if you remember,
quite an elaborate one at that.
This episode of a wedding with
such celebrations is common in
the literature of the period;
the most prominent one is in
the great poem by Luis de
Góngora,
whose name I may not have
mentioned before,
who is the great Baroque poet;
it is from him that you get the
word in English
"gongoristic"
as something very baroque and
complicated,
and he is famous for many
poems, but the most famous one
is called the Soledades,
and in the Soledades
there is quite an elaborate
wedding ceremony that is
described.
It is like a spring ritual,
a celebration of nature's
replenishment--remember that
Part II, vaguely begins sort of
in spring.
But in the whole episode one
wonders, is nature corrected by
art or does nature prevail?
I think the answer is obvious
that art prevails.
That art corrects nature,
and this is,
again, one of the main themes
in Part II of the
Quixote.
Don Quixote is on the side of
Basilio,
not of Camacho and in this the
episode is very remindful of
Marcela's and
Grisóstomo's in Part I,
when Don Quixote,
again, is on the side of
Marcela.
Perhaps this episode is the
kind of ending that the
Marcela-Grisóstomo
episode should have had in Part
I,
the reminiscences of that
episode also in the attempted or
faked suicide,
in Part I Grisóstomo,
as we saw, had actually
committed suicide.
Now, the story's a version of
the myth of Pyramus and
Thisbe,
which had been anticipated by
Lorenzo de Miranda's sonnet on
the topic during the episode at
Diego de Miranda's house,
his father's house,
the man in green,
and it's mentioned directly by
one of the students on the road
to the wedding.
It is also acted out in the
danza hablada,
the spoken dance,
the epithalamium,
during the wedding festivities.
So the myth of Pyramus and
Thisbe hangs heavily over
this episode.
John Sinnegan writes, quote:
"The occurrence of the
ceremony in a theater [theater
like]
implies that the wedding is but
one more artifice.
Therefore, when Basilio appears
we become caught up with the
spectators at the wedding.
They, like the audience at the
play were 'suspensos
esperando,' [they were
waiting in suspense to see what
would happen].
The heralded star of the play
has just stepped on stage and
everyone is anxious to see what
he will do."
Sinnegan adds,
comparing this episode,
which is the only one on love
on the second part with the
Cardenio tale of the first part,
and he writes the following.
This is rather a lengthy quote,
but I think a useful quote from
this John Sinnegan.
It goes; "The final result
of the action of Camacho's
wedding is the confirmation of
the propriety of romantic love
and the rejection of the
illegitimate claim on love by
greed.
The same conclusion was
provided by Cardenio's tale.
There are, however,
important differences between
the two stories.
Cardenio's tale ends in an inn,
to which the hand of fate had
led the two couples;
the Camacho wedding episode
however ends in a stage and the
conclusion is brought about by
Basilio's skill.
The difference between these
two endings reflects a
significant difference between
Part I and Part II.
In Part I, only Don Quixote and
the priest acted as authors in
the sense that they tried to
impose fiction on reality.
The role of art was of
secondary concern to the other
characters.
In Part II, however,
art and artifice are extremely
important and a larger number of
characters,
from Sancho Panza to the Duke
and Duchess and,
of course, Sansón
Carrasco,
act as authors by using fiction
to impose their wills on other
characters.
In Camacho's wedding Basilio
acts as author because he is not
content to let fate decide the
end of the story.
Therefore he imposes his will
on the other characters by using
fiction to alter the course of
the story away from its natural
ending."
Unquote.
He's the author but he's also
the actor of this play that he
has made up.
But another way to look at the
episode is to see it a modern
version of the Pyramus and
Thisbe myth which is clearly
in the background and looming,
as I've just said over the
story.
The Pyramus and Thisbe
story in Ovid's
Metamorphoses highlights
the pagan theme of suicide,
which Cervantes,
in his Catholic environment,
uses for dramatic effect but
ultimately avoids.
Now, Ovid, we all know who he
was,
and I gave you some information
in the sheet that I passed
around with the copy of this
episode in the
Metamorphoses;
he was a Roman poet of the last
Augustan age,
he's known for his Ars
Amatoria,
which someone called "the
most immoral work written by a
man of genius,"
it's on love--
don't rush out now to get the
book.
But the Metamorphoses is
his most important work,
which is a long narrative poem,
book,
which recounts legends in which
the miraculous transformations
of matter occur.
In fact, the poem begins:
"My intention is to tell
of bodies changed to different
forms."
And it begins with the change
from chaos to cosmos,
and goes on to the moment to
Julius Caesar being transformed
into a star.
So the Middle Ages took the
Metamorphoses to be kind
of a pagan bible,
like an old testament.
If the Old Testament tells the
story of the universe,
so does the
Metamorphoses using the
classical myths.
His influence in the
Renaissance was tremendous,
and even in the late Middle
Ages.
He was kind of the thesaurus of
myths that artists,
both painters,
sculptures, and writers used
very often.
Now, in Spanish literature he
was very influential as he was,
of course, in English
literature throughout the ages.
He competes with Virgil in
importance as a classical author
to be followed.
Now, there are deeper more
disturbing aspects in this
story,
in Camacho's wedding linking
deflowering,
blood and the connection
between life and death,
into which I will go in some
detail.
Love appears as a mock death to
promote life.
Violence and love are complicit
because violence is the subtext
of love.
The issue here is of classical
mythologies, version of this,
contrasted with Christian
doctrine.
The question for artists of the
Renaissance,
deeply interested in the
classical world,
but living in a Christian one,
was what to do with the ancient
gods.
The most common answer was
allegory;
the myths were seen as moral
allegories, they told a moral
tale.
But in the case of the episode
of Camacho's wedding what
Cervantes seems to be proposing
is a modern reenactment of an
ancient reoccurring dilemma
concerning love and using for
that the classical myth of
Pyramus and Thisbe.
Basilio's arts are used here to
steer the story away from its
pagan ending,
suicide, to a victory of love
and Christian marriage--
you have read the story in the
handout that I gave you in the
last class.
The pagan ending is turned into
theater, into representation,
into art.
Don Quixote has referred
earlier to marriage as an
irreparable accident,
in something that sounds very
funny to us today,
he is just using scholastic
terminology to refer to it,
and always in the context of
these debates about marriage
that I will revisit today.
Basilio makes the accidental
the result of choice,
his choice.
The point is that skill and
wiliness lead to a virtuous
result here.
The whole of the second part of
the Quixote is an apology
for art,
for the artificial,
for the constructed,
for the contrived,
for art helping nature attend
good ends,
after going through the process
of desengaño that
I have been underlining in the
past few classes.
It is a way of turning deceit,
which would normally lead to
disillusionment,
into a positive force that
leads to a happy ending.
As I said, Basilio's skills
prevail over the economic
forces, the social and economic
forces;
his craftiness wins the day.
Now, what I claim is beneath
all of that a kind of substory,
a subtext.
The story is a rewriting of the
love stories of Part I that turn
on unequal marriage and that
involve the issue of secret
marriages,
which, as I said,
were the hot topic of the day
which was taken up by the
Council of Trent.
Having read Elliott you know
now what the Council of Trent
was.
I spoke about these issues when
speaking about the episode in
which Dorotea allows herself to
be deflowered by Don Fernando.
The difference here is the
lurking presence of classical
myth, typical,
more typical of the Baroque.
In Part I the stories about all
of these young people seem to be
drawn from contemporary legal
archives,
contemporary stories about
conflicts involving social
issues,
states and legacies.
Here the source is much more
imposing and ancient,
the myth of Pyramus and
Thisbe,
but true to the political
character of Part II there is,
in addition,
a protracted discussion of the
issue of marriage by the
characters.
The issue of marriage was a
political issue,
not just a religious issue;
it's impossible to separate the
two.
Other echoes of Part I are
Basilio's madness,
when he hears of Quiteria's
impending marriage,
which recalls both
Grisóstomo and Cardenio
when they go mad--
in the case of Cardenio mostly,
we don't see Grisóstomo
actually act that out--
and, of course,
the issue of suicide which
evokes Grisóstomo.
This is another case,
I emphasize,
of rewriting episodes from Part
I,
so the rewritings involve here
both episodes in Part I and
classical myth,
which is being rewritten.
But there is a deeper take on
marriage at the level of
material transformations.
The story of Camacho's wedding
is about the issue of marriage
as a sacrament,
a transformation of matter for
transcendental purposes,
that of creating a new human
life and how it is
institutionalized through civil
and canon law,
that is, by society and
religion.
The law is based on
prohibition: 'thou shall not,'
here,
the ban instituted by
Quiteria's parents once she and
Basilio have reached sexual
maturity,
which is quite evident,
if you read the story their
prohibition comes up when they
have reached sexual maturity.
She has begun to menstruate and
he is now capable of
impregnating her.
Her parents are reluctant to
have her reproduce with an
impecunious Basilio who,
for all of his skills,
has no profitable ones.
But that stands also as does
simply the prohibition:
'that shall not.'
As we saw when discussing the
issue regarding Dorotea,
clandestine marriages--which is
lurking here in the background
because we must assume that
there had been one between
Basilio and Quiteria,
clandestine marriages could
lead to polygamy.
And I could say to any girl
that I was involved with,
yes, yes, I will marry you,
and then if it took,
as it were, you could be
married to several such women.
And also, how can a vow hastily
made in the heat of passion yoke
partners for life in what Don
Quixote calls,
again using scholastic
terminology,
"un accidente
irreparable,"
meaning something that cannot
be taken back,
in the Catholic Church you
cannot take it back.
That is, how can such--how can
words uttered in these
circumstances make a marriage?
How can freewill be so easily
surrendered?
The Council of Trent proclaimed
that the church abhorred
clandestine marriages and
ordered the clergy not to
celebrate weddings without
published bands and the presence
of witnesses.
This was incorporated by Philip
the Second into Spanish
statutory law in 1564 and
remained as the foundation of
marriage in Spain until the
nineteenth century.
The conflict is dealt with very
subtly in this story.
Basilio is proficient in canon
and civil law,
and he puts it to good use in
his trick to marry Quiteria.
How does he do that?
Well, he threatens to die
without confession.
I have to underline this
because, even if you are a
Catholic, this is very difficult
to conceive from a modern
perspective.
So, you want to die without
confession?
So what?
Go ahead, be my guest!
But, by threatening to do that,
he his accusing them of sending
him irrevocably to hell,
because suicide is a mortal
sin, and if he dies without
confession and commits suicide,
he's going to hell,
no matter what.
This is how he convinces
everyone;
he knows canon law and he knows
civil law.
So to die without confession if
she will not give in would
condemn him to eternal
damnation.
Quiteria and the others would
have done more harm to this way
than murdering him;
murdering him would be nothing
compared to eternal damnation.
Then he has both Quiteria and
himself utter the words about
free consent that would
legitimize the marriage before
church and society.
I'm sure you remember the
episode in which he insists,
and the proper words,
the legal words are used,
affirming consent.
She confirms later her
determination afterwards to
dispel any doubt about her
desires and make void any future
claims to dissolve the marriage;
that is, she confirms it
afterwards, so it wasn't just in
the spare of the moment,
she confirms that she wants to
marry Basilio.
All of these are very carefully
constructed episodes to show
Basilio's lawyerly skills.
But, as I am suggesting,
in this story Cervantes probes
deeper into the issue of
marriage, deeper than legal
issues.
He goes back to marriage as a
kind of transubstantiation,
a transcendental metamorphosis
of matter, a transformation of
matter.
The blending of bloods,
literally, that makes the union
indivisible, presumably.
In looking at the episode with
this background in mind it
appears that Cervantes is
favoring the clandestine "I
do" that Quiteria must have
articulated,
while at the same time having
her and Basilio observe the
rituals prescribed by the
Council of Trent.
It seems to be a middle course:
the sacramental nature of
marriage lurks in the subtext of
the story through the myth of
Pyramus and Thisbe.
It is a tragic story the myth
of Pyramus and Thisbe in
which a cruel fate befalls the
young lovers because of a
misinterpretation,
although it could be read as an
admonitory tale about the
recklessness of youth.
The myth goes back to the
conjunction of love and death at
the moment when love ripens and
is about to become regenerative.
Driven by desire,
the young lovers are to meet at
the tomb of Ninus,
where they die,
not killed by the lioness but
by their own hands.
The bloody veil can be seen as
an image of the hymen,
rent in the act of love,
a bloody event,
the renting of the hymen,
that also recalls the onset of
menstruation;
that is, the beginning of the
capacity for reproduction but
also the recurrent death of a
woman's ovum.
The red of the tree's fruit is
both a symbol of resurrection
and of death,
as it recalls menstruation in
their reoccurring coloring.
The myth reenacts a tragic
human predicament symbolized by
the spilling of blood at
conception,
birth and death,
leaving open the possibility
that the law,
here the parent's disapproval,
can overcome or forestall the
fatality of the situation.
But the prohibition is also
allied to death because it is
instrumental in bringing about
the tragic ending.
In Ovid, the conflict appears
to resolve itself in beauty,
the gorgeous red fruit of the
tree.
In Cervantes it goes further.
By way of contrast and
comparison we will later see how
Velázquez deals with
classical myth.
In Cervantes the myth of
Pyramus and Thisbe is
given in chards,
fragments, with a faint
outline, like a distant memory.
It looks forward towards Joyce,
the Ulysses,
where these fragments appear,
more than backwards to the
Middle Ages and the Renaissance
where the myths were more
coherent.
I am inclined to believe,
however, that Cervantes had
Ovid's text in front of him,
or that he had a prodigious
memory.
For instance,
when Basilio feigns being near
death, his eyes are part of the
act.
If you remember:
'his eyes already turn in his
head.'
He's playing that he's about to
die so he has his eyes turned
into his head,
which recalls the moment when
Thisbe asks Pyramus to answer
whereupon--
I'm not going to read you the
Latin because then I'm going to
really sound like a priest
saying mass--
the translation:
"He heard the name of
Thisbe and he lifted his eyes
with the weight of death heavy
upon them,
and saw her face and closed his
eyes."
So the eyes,
the element,
this is one of the chards that
I say remain of the myth.
My argument follows what I
would like to call or what I
like to call an "itinerary
of blood."
From the pregnant calf on the
spit that Sancho sees when they
arrive at the wedding which
foretells of the sacrificial
victim,
the groom, which he replaces.
It also recalls the violence at
weddings, Romeo and Juliet being
the most famous example in
western literature.
The violence,
the blood, announce gestation
and the spilling of more blood
as the new human being,
the most elemental purpose of
marriage is produced.
The consumption of the animals,
the wine and the bread have
obvious Christian symbolism,
too.
To consume and to consummate go
together in a wedding
celebration, as I said earlier.
They consume the world around
them including the earth through
the wine.
It is a form,
again, of transubstantiation.
Transubstantiation is the word
for the Eucharist,
when the body of Christ is
transformed into bread and wine.
That is of transforming one
substance into another through
actions that involve both
pleasure and violence:
hunting,
butchering, squashing the
grapes and, of course,
sex.
Basilio's intervention
postpones the blood Quiteria
would have shed in Camacho's bed
substituting it for the fake
blood that he has concealed.
This blood stains his garment;
the proxy blood suspends the
real blood that would seal the
marriage.
But I contend that there is
another hidden blood that
forestalls the consummation of
the intended marriage between
Camacho and Quiteria.
And you don't have to follow me
on this or be persuaded if you
don't want.
To put it bluntly,
I think that Quiteria is
menstruating on her wedding day.
In the Spanish original,
it says: "Venía la
hermosa Quiteria algo
descolorida y debía ser
de la mala noche que siempre
pasan las novias en componerse
para el día venidero de
sus bodas."
Jarvis: "The fair Quiteria
looked a little pale occasioned
perhaps by want of rest the
preceding night which brides
always employ in setting
themselves off and dressing for
their wedding day
following."
"Descolorida"
in the Spanish does not just
mean pale,
a little pale,
but to have lost one's color,
because of an illness,
or a fright.
And "componerse"
means to dress up,
of course, but also to recover
from an illness.
Why mention that she's pale?
I believe that the suggestion
is that she's menstruating.
Menstruation is fraught with
all kinds of prohibitions and
lore in all cultures,
in ours going back all the way
to the Old Testament.
Now, menstruation,
in this case,
would have been a providential
blood that would have impeded
the consummation of Camacho's
marriage postponing Quiteria's
hymeneal blood and preserving it
for Basilio's bed.
Quiteria's menstruation,
her regla,
which is another word of saying
menstruation in Spanish,
and it means,
"rule,"
simply "rule"
would be a superior law
inherent in the blood itself in
determining the outcome of the
conflict.
Marriage is seen as ordained by
God part of a divine plan that
supersedes custom or law and
overrides considerations of
unequal social status.
The process of marriage is
embedded in bloods itself,
in the general transformation
of matter according to divine
grace.
In the Bible,
man and woman would become one
flesh in marriage.
In Ovid's pagan version there
is no salvation possible,
the lover's fusion is only
achieved as ashes in a funerary
urn or in the beauty of a
mulberry tree in bloom.
In Cervantes,
a form of justice has been
made,
and that is every reason to
believe that the commingling of
bloods will lead to
regeneration,
to the birth of a new human
being.
This is a kind of conclusion
that we did not find in Part I,
where marriages are yet to
occur, except in the tale about
foolish curiosity where there is
also a great deal of blood,
if you remember.
I think that in a deep sense
Cervantes is true to Ovid and to
the spirit of
Metamorphoses,
"meta,"
movement
"morphoses"
the change of form,
but has given it a Christian
twist and translated it into the
present.
In Cervantes,
the myth is not retold with a
didactic satirical or even
aesthetic purpose.
In fact, it is not so much
retold, as recycled.
It is not an Ovide
Moralisé,
which was--from 1340--was a
book in French by Pierre
Bersuire,
which influenced many writers,
including Chaucer,
and into which fifteen books or
chapters of the
Metamorphoses are turned
into allegories,
as I mentioned before,
moral allegories.
Here this is not what Cervantes
does at all either on the level
of marriage as a social
institution and so forth,
or that deeper level that I'm
claiming is told in this
substory or subtext that I
called the itinerary of blood.
Now in this use of myth
Cervantes resembles
Velázquez.
So let us turn to
Velázquez again,
and now we have to douse the
lights or put the curtains down,
and Elena is going to be good
enough to be showing us some
paintings by Velázquez
that I just want to discuss in
this context.
So if you wait a minute for the
theatrical part of the
presentation today to be
prepared, as it were.
All the way down,
all the way down.
Over there it cannot go all the
way down...
Okay, that's good enough.
And then we turn off the lights
and I have to let my eyes adjust
so that I can read my notes.
Let's go to Los
borrachos.
Ok.
The Spanish philosopher
José Ortega y Gasset,
whom I have mentioned before,
but I think that I want you to
remember him as part of--
can you see from this side?
No.
I mentioned him before;
he's the most important Spanish
philosopher of the twentieth
century,
known in this country mostly
for his book The Revolution
of the Masses,
but also--he also should be
read for many books,
but one is The
Dehumanization of Art,
which is about the avant-garde
art.
In any case,
the Spanish philosopher Ortega
y Gasset claimed that what
Velázquez meant by mixing
classical gods with unsavory or
ordinary characters from every
day reality is that there are no
gods and no transcendental
meaning,
if we take the gods to be the
representation of the higher
sense of things when seen in
connection to each other.
Velázquez,
he says is, I quote now Ortega:
"...an atheistic giant,
a colossal impious man.
With his brush he banishes the
gods as if smacking them with a
broom [I love this simile
because you can think of the
brush as a little broom]
in his Bacanal [which is
this painting,
known in Spanish as Los
borrachos,
The Drunks]
there is not only no Baccus but
a rascal impersonating Baccus.
Bacanal has nine
figures, two of which seem to be
dressed,
rather undressed for a bacanal
[bacanals are feasts in honor of
Baccus,
the god of wine,
celebrated in the spring and
fall.
These two guys who are near
naked].
The others are lusty peasants
roughly clothed in contemporary
dress and with the same sort of
casual not posed air that
characterized the naturalistic
genre scenes called in Spain
"bodegones"
[which is simply "still
lifes" in English,
in Spanish they're called
"bodegones"].
This painting sought and
achieved the effect of a
casually chosen slice of life.
But Bacanal is carefully
composed around the light flesh
of the bogus Baccus at the
center."
Jonathan Brown says--he's one
of the great experts on
Velázquez;
he wrote a book with Elliott on
Spanish architecture,
that attempts to interpret that
painting,
quote: "as a parody of the
Olympian gods or as a sermon on
the evils of drink have failed,
and instead Velázquez
intended to represent Baccus as
a giver of the gift of wine
which freed man temporarily from
the harsh unforgiving struggle
of daily life.
Deprived of the beneficent
liquid, the beggar finds no
respite from the hardships which
in sober moments will be shared
by all of the company."
This marvelous painting hangs
at the Prado Museum,
and if you remember the words
by Auerbach about the subtle
plastic nature of Cervantes'
art,
of his depiction of things and
of sensuous,
you can see that there is,
besides the connection I'm
trying to establish here,
a kinship between Cervantes'
art and that of
Velázquez,
and you can imagine these
characters as appearing in
episodes of the Quixote,
I'm sure.
Look at the face of stupor on
this drunk, he has sort of a
grin of stupidity and
drunkenness, and the others,
you know?
The Spinners,
Las hilanderas,
was painted around 1657,
it is thus a very late work,
contemporaneous with Las
Meninas,
and nearly as complex and as
ambitious.
In it, Velázquez has
combined two subjects,
one from the classical
mythology and the other from his
own time.
It is a commonplace work scene,
as you can see.
There are, in fact,
two stories from classical
mythology combined in the
picture: the fable of
Arachne and the story of
Jupiter's Rape of Europa.
In the foreground we have the
activities of tapestry
manufacturing as was done in the
factories under royal patronage
in Madrid,
and in the alcove,
in the back,
the classical tale of the
weaver Arachne.
The scene takes place at
Arachne's shop,
where, as a great artist,
she's visited by elegant
ladies.
The tapestry hanging on the
back wall of the alcove,
which is presumably Arachne's
work, is the key to the
relationship between the two
scenes.
It is a woven copy of Tizian's
The Rape of
Europa--Could you give me
that painting?
This is the actual painting by
Tizian, The Rape of
Europa which--back to the
Hilanderas--which we find
in the back, in that tapestry.
The Rape of Europa is
one of the most celebrated of
Jupiter's erotic adventures with
mortal women;
Arachne has challenged Minerva,
patroness of weavers and
goddess of wisdom to a weaving
contest.
It was called a draw,
but because Arachne's tapestry
was judged to be the equal of
Minerva's,
and further,
because it depicted such a
scandalous act by her father,
the goddess punished Arachne by
turning her into a spider.
The story is also drawn from
Ovid's Metamorphoses,
book six.
This is the reason Minerva is
shown gesturing angrily.
Jonathan Brown,
again, believes that by,
quote:
"by inserting a quotation
from this famous work,
The Rape of
Europa into the composition
Velázquez implies his
believe in the nobility and
transcendental value of the art
of painting.
In The Spinners,
Velázquez seeks to
reconcile the artificial world
of myth with a palpable world of
visual reality without
sacrificing the decorum required
by the one and the
verisimilitude by the other [the
decorum by the classical myth
and the verisimilitude,
the realism by the other].
The contrast [he goes on]
between the foreground where
sturdy women toil at burdensome
tasks and the refined atmosphere
of the artist's atelier [the
scene in the back]
is perhaps Velázquez's
way of implying his conviction
about the distinction between
craft and art."
While this is fine--that's the
end of the quote by Jonathan
Brown--
and at the time there was a
raging dispute as to whether
painters were artists or mere
artisans;
this may seem strange to us but
there was.
And, of course,
Tizian had been a favorite
painter of Charles the Fiftg,
the previous century,
and Philip the Second,
so the painting is in homage to
him,
and there is no doubt that by
inserting Tizian's painting into
his Velázquez is putting
himself at the same level.
But there is a lot more to it,
it seems to me,
as in Las Meninas there
seems to be a revelation of the
act of artistic creation,
which in the painting has to do
with Minerva and Arachne,
but that taking the whole work
into consideration has to do
with Velázquez's own
creation.
Creation appears as a layered
process that involves the real--
this is the real--either
because art is a reflection of
reality or because art
illuminates reality,
but also because reality
unveils the artificiality of
art.
In The Spinners we have
paintings within paintings,
and the presence in the
foreground--
and the present,
this is the present in the
foreground--
appears as a repetition of the
classical past.
But it is a repetition that is
also a comedown:
can the present day spinners
recall the myth of Arachne?
It seems to me that what
Velázquez is doing,
as Ortega y Gasset suggested
about the Bacanal this
diminishing the gods,
and also by showing Minerva's
studio within the weaving shop,
he's showing the inner recesses
of representation:
it's backstage tricks,
as it were, and as he showed in
Las Meninas.
The whole painting is a
desengaño, is in
other words is what I'm trying
to say.
What we take to be gods are
like today's spinners.
The weaver's shop is no
different from Minerva's studio
in both the deception of art are
created to deceive man.
We see the contemporary weavers
in relation to the classical
fable,
and we see at the center of
Velázquez's painting a
quotation from a masterpiece.
It is, again,
an infinitely receding
sequence,
a play of mirrors within this
workshop of representation that
we are being given here,
which is like giving us a
workshop of
engaño,
therefore by giving us that
workshop,
it is a desengaño.
Now, the process is similar to
what Cervantes does in Camacho's
wedding episode,
and of the whole of the
Quixote dealing with myth.
The fable of Pyramus and
Thisbe takes place in
fabulous Babylon;
Camacho's wedding takes place
in an insignificant village in
Spain.
What Basilio does is to use the
artistry of the fable to deceive
those in attendance,
particularly Camacho and his
friends,
but also Don Quixote,
Sancho and even the reader,
who does not know what is
happening until the moment that
the trick is revealed to bring
the story to a climax and
eventual resolution.
There is a mirroring of myth
and present reality,
and the elaboration of a deceit
through artistry,
acting, playing the role of the
mythological Pyramus--
Basilio playing that role,
acting it out.
It is both an
engaño and a
desengaño,
making up the whole story.
The backstage of representation
is displayed as in Las
Meninas,
and as we shall soon see in the
episode involving Maese Pedro,
Ginés de Pasamonte as
puppeteer and most revealingly
in the culminating episode in
the whole of the Quixote,
the one about Montesinos cave,
in which we are given the whole
underpinning of Don Quixote's
madness,
his actual subconscious.
Now, whereas in Part I
Cervantes seems to be addressing
the romances of chivalry and the
picaresque as models and
sources,
in Part II he takes up the
grand tradition of Homer,
Ovid, Virgil and Dante,
particularly in episodes such
as the cave of Montesinos and
the pageant in the forest that
we will be seeing soon.
This is very significant.
It seems to me that he now
knows that he is in their league
and that he has created a
literary character that will
endure like theirs and like the
characters in classical
mythology.